welcome to the man of recaps this is the
handmaid's tale seasons one through four
now the show features incredibly
disturbing content but i'm not going to
show any or go into too much detail so
you can get the story without living
through the trauma welcome to gilead the
rebranded name for a near future america
that is descended into a
christian-themed dystopian nightmare
women in particular are the most
oppressed group who have lost all
personal freedom apparently this all
started when the world faced a crisis of
infertility so the fertile women in
gilead have been rounded up and put in
the red robes as handmaids this
handmaid's tale is the story of june who
we meet in season one as offred which is
of fred because she's the property of
her commander fred waterford he and his
wife serena being unable to get pregnant
it's their handmaid's job to bear
children for them and sojune is forced
to take part in the ceremony a
government-mandated god-approved rape so
it's an awful life for handmaids and
they can't even trust each other because
any of them could be true believers that
are spying for the secret police the
eyes and so their conversations are
nothing but these pious platitudes
blessed be the fruit praise be but one
day june and her walking partner emily
decide they can trust each other in fact
emily's like hey i'm with the resistance
mayday your commander fred waterford's
real high up there see if you can start
like spying on him and soon an
opportunity presents itself when he
invites her in to play scrabble this is
super illegal because women aren't
allowed to read but you know the rules
don't apply to commanders so things are
looking up june's made contact with the
resistance and now has a mission but the
very next day emily's been replaced they
didn't find out she's with the
resistance just that she's gay which is
very illegal in gilead and emily's
disappeared but june continues her
scrabble games with fred he starts
opening up to her in fact he almost
seems like a nice guy until it becomes
apparent that being nice to her is just
a sick power trip for him and he's a
disgusting pig soon he gets bored of
scrabble and takes her out on the town
to the brothel jezebels an unofficial
funhouse for high-ranking commanders but
this is good news for the resistance who
has a package there june can pick up so
she has to pretend to be into fred so
he'll take her back and more good news
working at jezebel's is moira june's
best friend from before the fall so with
moyra's help june gets the package out
but it's not a bomb or anything it's a
stack of letters written by women all
over gilead telling the truth of how bad
it is here and as for moira she decides
it's time to escape and makes it to the
safety of canada now let's meet mrs
waterford fred's wife serena who
sometimes is very nice to june but other
times is incredibly cruel more than
anything though she really wants a baby
and when jun doesn't get pregnant she
finally admits it might be fred's fault
so she has a secret very illegal plan to
make june try with another man and she
has in mind their driver nick who's a
generally nice guy and jun and nick
can't say no here serena has all the
power over them so they go through with
it but later june sneaks down there like
hey boy i'm ready to take my sexual
autonomy back let's do it because we
want to and so june and nick get it on
with some passionate consensual sex now
like most drivers nick does in fact
report to the eyes but he's no true
believer he's just doing what he has to
do to survive and he and june truly fall
in love but by the way june had a family
before gilead her husband luke and
daughter hannah during their escape june
got caught but luke did make it out to
canada and we check on him once in a
while but tragically their daughter
hannah was also captured she's been
placed with another family and jun is
never allowed to see her again but now
serena's plan worked and jun is pregnant
when a handmaid has a baby she gives it
up to the host family and is immediately
reassigned now handmaids are trained and
overseen by the ants and the leader here
is aunt lydia a real nasty person who's
a gilead true believer this one woman
janine wouldn't submit so aunt lydia
punished her severely by taking her eye
and it kinda broke her now janine's
taking her baby back and threatens to
jump off the bridge with it didn't think
she talked her down but no she just
handed the baby over and now she jumps
janine survives the fall but now she's
gonna be executed by having the other
handmaid stone her to death but jun's
like no way not one of our own so she
drops the rock sorry aunt lydia and all
the other handmaids join in yeah they're
standing up for each other and so season
one ends with a moment of empowerment
tez handmaids are sticking together but
as season two begins the punishment is
severe it's like hey you thought your
life was bad before we can make it even
worse but the ringleader june is being
spared the worst of the punishment
because she's pregnant but aunt lydia is
like don't get too comfortable if you
misbehave there's still ways we can
punish you so june's back on her best
behavior for now there's some excitement
at her checkup when a nurse leaves her
key to escape yes nick has arranged an
escape plan to get her to canada but
long story short it doesn't work one of
the many many times june almost escapes
nick covers up his involvement in fact
for his loyal service to gilead he's
rewarded with a way too young wife long
story short gilead has horribly
brainwashed her and she thinks it's her
fault that nick won't sleep with her and
she ends up falling in love with one of
the other guards but that's very illegal
and they're both put to death in the
public swimming pool fred and serena
waterford take a trip on a diplomatic
mission to canada basically the whole
world denounces gilead but i mean it's
still got america's military so they
can't do too much about it and they do
need to trade serena befriends an agent
of the american government in exile more
on him later the canada crew moira and
luke do what they can to protest in fact
nick finds luke like hey jun's alive
she's okay relatively and he gives him
the package of letters from gilead so
luke and moira put it on the internet
and now the whole world denounces gilead
even more later nick's able to arrange a
meeting between june and her daughter
hannah yeah mother daughter reunited
although briefly but just that nick's
called away and june finds herself
unsupervised near the canadian border
yes it's time to escape but oh no what's
this the baby's coming right now and
june gives birth by herself a beautiful
baby girl she can't trek through the
snow with a newborn so june comes back
and serena waterford's got her baby
nicole now commander waterford's big
project is building a fancy new red
center but one of the handmaids doesn't
like that smuggles in a bomb and blows
that place up unfortunately fred
survived but he's out of commission for
a while but this is bad news because in
gilead a commander can go from top dog
to executed for treason real quick and
bring his whole house down with him so
serena says he's still working from the
hospital but really she's doing the work
and forging his signatures she brings in
june to help because she was an editor
and so for a while the women are running
the show now back at the start of the
gilead movement the waterfords were a
team in fact serena was the rock star
until the movement shifted to be more
about oppressing women and serena found
herself no longer part of the decision
making and now in the world she helped
create the book she wrote in support of
gilead it's illegal for her to read but
when fred gets back instead of thanking
his wife for covering for him he's real
mad and decides to punish her so
serena's had enough she gathers up a
bunch of commander's wives like hey
we're loyal to gilead but we deserve to
be treated a little bit better and so in
a bold act she pulls out a bible and
reads a passage but the men of the
council were not moved by her bravery
and in fact they punish her according to
the law and cut off her pinky serena has
often been june's greatest enemy but now
june hopes she can find an ally in her
now by the way we know about handmaids
but infertile women of low status work
as domestic servants called martha's one
night there's a fire down the street and
the waterford's martha rita is like hey
june this is a distraction we're getting
you and the baby out unfortunately
serena catches her but jun's like hey
you just saw how awful gilead is you
can't possibly want to raise a daughter
in this place and serena's just in the
right mindset to agree she lets baby
nicole go so the martha network helps
june escape it's like wait here there's
a truck to canada coming but first we
gotta go check in on the colonies yeah
the colonies are a threat to where you
could be banished to apparently some
part of america got nuked and uh people
are sent here to clean it up and die and
one of the women banished here was
june's first friend emily but in the
explosion at the red centre a lot of
handmaids died so they need to replace
mints congrats emily you're a sex slave
again but her new commander is joseph
lawrence who's a grumpy professor type
and he's like look we don't do the
ceremony here and this house is actually
kind of chill aunt lydia though is not
chill so one day emily grabs a knife and
stabs her yeah knocks her down the
stairs amanda lawrence is going to help
her escape so is jun's waiting for the
canada truck now her friend emily's
coming with but at the last minute june
decides she's staying behind what you
know yes her daughter hannah is still in
gilead though and june's decided she's
not leaving without her june staying
behind to help with the resistance and
this is a good time as any to make fun
of the fact that 90 of the show is june
dramatically staring at the camera so
now jun comes back like hey i got the
baby to canada serena though is still in
some kind of mood she decides to burn
her house down june's like yeah girl i
get it let that mother burn so the
waterford house is toast june gets
transferred to a new commander she's no
longer of fred she's now of joseph
unfortunately though he's not actually a
part of the resistance which he tries to
convince me he should do more to help
but he's like yo there's only so much i
could do he doesn't much care what you
get up to though as long as it doesn't
cause him trouble so some of martha's
like to meet up here to talk resistant
stuff and jun's like yo girls i'm in now
emily and baby nicole did make it to the
safety of canada she meets up with jun's
husband luke and her best friend moira
like hey guys you're the god parents of
this baby now remember right before she
escaped emily stabbed in lydia and
pushed her down the stairs but aunt
lydia survived she's a tough old bird
and her brush with death did not make
her any nicer if anything she's worse
than ever now there's bad blood between
the waterfords serena's still mad at
fred for not fighting for when they cut
off her pinky but when serena sees a
video of baby nicole in canada she
regrets her decision to let her go she
wants her back so they start the
propaganda campaign asking canada to
return her to her home they travel to
the capital of gilead old washington dc
with the washington monument turned into
a big cross and so working on this with
commander waterford is high commander
winslow he's a real top dog and he's
living the gilead dream he's got like a
dozen kids by a dozen different
handmaids this makes june try to reason
with serena like hey you can't possibly
want to raise a daughter in this place
but serena's baby crazy she's like yeah
i kind of do though these two have a big
fight in front of the destroyed lincoln
memorial june's hoping serena would be
an ally for her but that ain't gonna
happen so with her husband fred fighting
so hard to get their baby back things
get better between them they make up but
he's lying to her they've decided to
keep baby nicole over there because it
gives him a lot of political leverage
now newly stationed in the capital is
driver nick who's been promoted to a
commander himself he and june are
briefly reunited but he can't really use
his newfound powers to help they're
shipping him off to the front of chicago
to brutally quash the rebellion there
yeah he's just in too deep so back in
the boston area a friend tells june
where her daughter hannah goes to school
june goes to mrs lawrence for help but
she's a reclusive shut-in she's got some
mental issues including high anxiety but
june convinces her to go for a walk and
befriends her enough that she's like
yeah let's go find your daughter but
with children so rare and valuable
schools are heavily guarded june can't
even see her just scares her across the
wall to avoid future incidents they now
transferred hannah far away even
commander lawrence doesn't have the
files but this ordeal's made june
realize that she was being selfish
thinking only of her own daughter all
the handmaids have kids around the area
and jun's got a new mission she wants to
get them all out but soon after they get
some visitors on ritual night yeah the
higher-up's thinking suspicious that not
a single one of his handmaids have ever
gotten pregnant they're here to watch
ensure he does the ritual and so we
thought june's days of being
ritualistically raped were over but it's
happening again he's like yo i'm so
sorry about this but she's like hey you
made this world now you gotta live in it
the silver lining though after this he's
all in he's getting his wife out and
gonna bring some kids with him so they
put it out through the martha network to
see how many are interested in helping
smuggle kids if they send muffins it
means yes and we got 52 muffins luckily
the resistance has a plane coming in to
deliver supplies so june's got to go
back to the brothel jezebels to convince
the bartender who's running the plane to
load it up with kids before he sends it
back out but she's recognized by
commander winslow and though she comes
up with a pretty good lie for why she's
here by herself there's no way she's
getting out of this without having sex
with him but no she decides to fight
back this time grabs a pen and stabs him
with it then boom kills this guy june's
gonna be in big trouble though luckily
housekeeping's here to help and luckily
the next day there's a bigger news story
that overshadows his disappearance
serena finally realized fred was
intentionally keeping nicole over there
for political reasons so she's been
talking to the american cia to back
channel a deal to give up fred in
exchange she can live in canada have
visitation with baby nicole but fred's
like yo serena ain't innocent either she
got immunity for anything that the laws
of gilead forced her to do but remember
she went outside the law to force jun
and nick to have sex so she could take
their baby though they had a consensual
relationship later that first time they
couldn't say no so serena raped them and
she's getting justice too meanwhile mrs
lawrence is doing worse than ever and
one night june finds her overdosing oh
she's gotta run and get help but wait if
they call an ambulance that'll bring
more attention on this house than ever
and operation children escape is only a
week away and so june has her walter
white breaking bad moment she leaves the
room and pretends she didn't see
anything and so finally the big day is
here and under the cover of night the
marthas bring the kids under their
charge to the house and so they journey
through the woods make it to the airport
but no why is there security here jean's
like hey i'll distract them you take the
kids around the other side but janine's
like nah girl handmade stick together
and all the women are throwing rocks to
distract him and the antigens leading
this guy away through the woods and oh
she gets shot but when he goes to grab
her the boot pistol blam gets him and
the plane flies away the plan worked
over 50 children safely in canada luke
gets the bad news that his wife june is
not on the plane but the bittersweet
news that she organized this whole thing
she's a hero and as for june she's okay
the bullet just clipped her and the
other handmaids are there to help but
now this group of about a dozen
handmaids are extremely wanted on their
run but they make it to the safe house
it's a country estate in the middle of
nowhere so not many visitors commander
keys has gone senile he has no idea
what's happening so it's his young wife
mrs keys who's happy to host some
resistance heroes and you might think a
commander's wife has had it better than
the handmaids but she has not she's also
been raped by her husband and all the
guards in the area in fact they capture
one of them so june strings them up and
it's like alright girl you could kill
him it's like yeah girl get that revenge
but also june should you have let the 14
year old do it it's complicated i guess
pretty soon june sneaks over to a nearby
estate to meet with their mayday contact
the fugitive handmaids can't stay in any
one place for too long so she's got
another safe house lined up for him but
in the meantime this house is a giant
party brothel for high-ranking military
commanders jun's like yo while we got
him all here we should kill him mrs keys
being a country girl knows which berries
are poisonous puts it in the liquor at
the party house yeah drink up commanders
yeah june just winning all over the
place until back at the house oh what no
the eyes found them and leading this
mission the new commander of the eyes it
is nick it's like hey june sorry i'm
gonna do what i can to protect you but i
can't stop this so june's brought to the
serious prison where she's reunited with
aunt lydia who's very mad at her the
other handmaid's moved on before they
got there so they're gonna torture june
to find out where they are finally
though they bring out the big guns yes
it's june's daughter hannah but she was
very young when she was taken away and
it's been like five years she barely
remembers her mom she's scared of this
creepy lady this is heartbreaking for
june it basically destroys her but still
to protect her daughter she gives up the
other handmaids before she leaves though
nick managed to arrange a rendezvous for
them and she runs up and these two start
smooching i mean as a top commander he
was complicit in her torture but like
also he still cares about her and wants
to protect her and she knows from their
past relationship that he is a good guy
he's just doing what he has to survive
in gilead just like the rest of them so
i don't know it's complicated so she's
back in red it's handmade time again but
they get stuck at a train crossing and
the guard's like hey i'm gonna go out
and take a leak and it's an incredible
tense scene as without talking all these
women realize that the only person
guarding them right now is aunt lydia so
oh june grabs her they're making a break
for it if they get across the tracks in
time they'll have a huge head start got
a pretty good shot at freedom come on
run for it oh no too late hit by a train
out of all those minor character
handmaids we've gotten to know and love
over the course of the series it's only
june and janine who survive these two
decide their best bet is to hop a train
headed for chicago remember that's the
front where the resistance is still
fighting and luckily this train is
ambushed by the resistance so june and
janine off to the war zone of chicago
now back in gilead commander lawrence is
in big trouble because it was his
handmade june who helped all those kids
escape so at first they're going to
execute him but he's still the smartest
guy they've got in terms of
macroeconomics and international
relations so they decide to keep him
alive as a consultant he's like look to
improve diplomatic relations we need a
ceasefire on the chicago border to allow
humanitarian aid in but the other
commanders don't want to listen to him
meanwhile aunt lydia after letting those
handmaids escape she's being pushed out
forcibly retired so she goes to see
commander lawrence and demands to be
reinstated she's like hey i've got all
sorts of blackmail on you about stuff
you've done that's not legal in gilead
but commander lawrence is like hey i
have no power here anyway but do you
have blackmail on the other commanders
indeed she does so these two use that to
get aunt lydia reinstated and commander
lawrence officially back in power
unfortunately though right before the
ceasefire they've decided to do one
final bombing run oh no june run girls
june is shell-shocked but alive and
luckily the humanitarian aid's coming in
right now and in fact the first one here
who finds june is her old best friend
moira and so it's finally happening
after three and a half seasons of
torture in gilead june has finally made
it to canada she joins up with the
canada crew all her friends she helped
escape gilead including her baby nicole
and she's reunited with her husband luke
who is overjoyed that she's finally free
and by the way janine also survived the
bombing and there's another new handmade
here it is the young mrs keys esther
lester's like no way i'm not giving in
things can't get any worse but janine's
like yo girl look at my eye things can
get much worse so for now esther's on
her best behavior blessed be the fruit
and all that and sojun enjoys living in
a free society again but being in gilead
all these years has left its mark she
went through so much trauma it's gonna
take time to adjust at the gilead
support group for women who made it out
moyers of the thought that hey we gotta
move past our drama but jun's kind of
like why should we move past it we
should get angry and all the other girls
are kinda with her now remember also in
canada are the waterfords fred and
serena but soon serena gets some very
surprising news she is pregnant last
season these two had an actual tender
moment where they got it on but how is
this possible serena was thought to be
infertile and fred was also thought to
be infertile it's a miracle i guess
serena still rightfully hates fred but
now they've got a bigger problem because
june osborne is here to testify against
them so june tells her story to the
world basically doing a full seasons 1-3
recap so serena decides they need to
present a united front so they make a
deal fred tells the international
community everything they could possibly
want to know about the inner workings of
gilead in exchange for immunity yes
commander waterford is going to walk
free and as you might imagine june is
not happy june goes to the american fbi
agent tuella like hey i've got a better
offer for you she set up a meeting with
commander lawrence and now that fred's
talking they really want him back before
he can spill more gilead secrets they're
willing to trade for him 22 prisoners
women that were in the resistance and
tuella's got to admit saving all of them
is worth more than fred's intel and so
just as commander waterford thinks he's
free it's like sorry man change of plans
they take him back to gilead where he's
certainly gonna be put to death nick
brings him out into the woods but he's
not killing him cause june osborne is
here in person and she's not alone she
brought all the women of the support
group with her and she's like you better
run and yes commander waterford running
for his life getting to experience just
a taste of what these women have been
through pretty soon they catch him and
finally june has him in her power they
beat him to death and though it's
extremely violent there's nothing
complicated about this one he got what
he deserved it probably will be
complicated for serena though we'll see
how she reacts actually june sends her a
package with fred's finger oh so after
violently beating a man to death june
goes on home and doesn't bother taking a
shower for luke this might be too much
he was all good with him getting sent to
gilead and executed but june doing it
herself in such a brutal way i mean
that's a lot and june recognizes this in
fact she says i'm gonna go and that's
where the handmaid's tale season 4 comes
to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]